we're doing a new segment called job  interview his name is Jason Lee come on  in Jason  enthusiasm like he's on Price is Right  why do you want to work here  after my first part-time job I got  scarred I never want to work in the Food  Services the customers man it's entitled  Karen came in one time she tried to do  that [ __ ] where you like get the [ __ ]  for free okay how about this you sing a  song try to tell Karen she can't get a  refund back okay  [Music]  I'm sorry  [Music]  wow you're such a [ __ ] please get the  [ __ ] out of here  [Music]  [Music]  I hope your kids don't get into college  leave no seriously get the [ __ ] out of  here get the [ __ ] out of here  also should say Parental Guidance